we had one other experience that was
pretty strange that's told in true
hallucinations
i tell it because i guess you should
know this
but kat and i were in hawaii one time in
this little
uh way out on this lava flow
and we've been taking mushrooms pretty
steadily
like twice a week or so and if you do
that if you really want your world to
come apart
take mushrooms every four days for 20
days
and i guarantee you you'll be pleading
for mercy at the end of it because
things will have gotten so weird
so anyway we were out on this lava flow
and we took mushrooms and it was the
third trip
and i got into this we were inside and i
got into this
dialogue with the thing on the subject
of
i always it's part of every trip almost
is this
i want you to do something i want you to
give a sign
in 3d i want you to show me something
in 3d and then we got into this wrangle
about the propulsion system of the
flying saucer
and i was saying you know i want to see
the ship and he was saying if we show
you the ship you'll understand how it
works and i'm saying look i'm the grower
don't hold out on me and
this thing was going back and forth and
about that time
cat tugged on my arm and said i feel
very very hot and i have to go outside
so it was a great effort for both of us
to move outside we could barely stand
and we got outside
she kept she could not maintain her
consciousness
she kept like fainting which i'd never
seen this
and um you know i was very loaded
but i i it shouldn't have been happening
and
and then i went through this thing you
know who you going to call
the famous question who you're going to
call and realizing
there's no one on this island who knows
anything about this except me and i
don't know anything about it
and i'm you know slapping her around
come out of it
come out of it and she can but then she
loses it again
and it slowly dawned on me actually not
so slowly but like over about five
seconds
that she was going to die that i had
finally
done it and i had pushed myself into
this situation and this thing was going
to happen
and i actually saw it like unfolding in
my mind i saw myself carrying her
into the forest and sitting with her
while she died we had no car
we had no telephone did nothing and
and then as i ran this movie again of me
walking with her
into the woods i saw myself walking past
the overflow trough from the rain
catchment system that gathers water and
i thought
i'll put her in water and i stood up
to take her and i was so smashed and it
was just a sea of hallucination and i
had a pair of drawstring pants i
remember
that came loose and fell down around my
ankles so i had my pants around my
ankles
and i was carrying this woman
frankenstein
style back through the darkness and
she's
absolutely out and and we get back to
the trot to this thing
and i layer down on the ground and i
pick up a bucket of water
and just let her have it you know and
then another one
and then i i realize that i figured it
out
and that she's going to live and that
this was
the thing to do and she's now talking to
me and saying
you know do it do more it's burning me
make every part of my body
cold and wet and so maybe 30 seconds
has elapsed and now i'm down on the
ground in the mud
embracing her she's hysterical we're
both laughing
and crying all this thing and the forest
edge
is just about from me to you right there
and suddenly from within the forest
comes this sound of the most
crazed demonic laughter you can possibly
imagine i mean hollywood eat your heart
out
it was just absolutely appalling
and we just grabbed each other
and ran for the house and
um it was it was never
explained what it was but somehow she
had gotten
more loaded than i think she had broken
through to some place i've never been
on mushrooms because after i brought her
into the house
i still i drew a bath and i kept putting
her into beds and taking her out
and she would go into these
and i said what's happening what's
happening and she said
ferns are growing out of everything
everything is putting off
and with my three-dimensional
hallucinations with eyes open
so it was a case i think of just getting
very very
deeply into it what was happening for
her
in those periods when i was slapping her
around and trying to wake her up
was she could see hovering over the
house
far larger than the house itself a
structure made out of rods of light
in which the shovel-faced mantis-like
creatures were there
and she said they felt like
hyperdimensional pirates
they were not part of the mushroom the
mushroom she said
was appalled that we all had been
we all had run across some roving
bad guys and the mushroom was saying you
know
let's all just hunker down here and be
quiet
for a few minutes and these guys will
go on stories
lots of stories
[Music]
you